let's answer a few questions first one
today is from milla milla says what's
the closest you came to dying that you
are aware of yeah I mean I think that
that you are aware of is a good caveat
because you know I don't know there were
probably situations where maybe on a
plane there was a situation where I
never even found out that there was some
kind of a issue up front and it was
closer to a plane crash than anybody
ever knew I don't really know I mean at
my guess is if there was almost the
plane crash I would have noticed
something from sitting in on the plane
but but maybe not I don't know and plane
crashes are very unlikely but have you
ever been to a car accident of some sort
I've been rear-ended uh I've not been in
an accident where I thought you know if
I was a foot to the left or a foot to
the right I could have died what I have
experienced many times though are sort
of near misses in cars where there's
someone who is not paying attention and
at the very last moment one or both of
the drivers sort of make an erratic move
with the car and you avoid an accident
altogether it's hard to imagine that it
would have been nothing or death right
more likely it would have been nothing
or an accident where you might have been
somewhat injured there's this one thing
I remember where I was I think about 10
years old and I was riding my bicycle on
a bike path in western Massachusetts and
I remember my dad was writing sort of
ahead of me and I sort of drifted you're
supposed to stay to the right much like
on roads in the United States and I sort
of started drifting over to the left and
I was looking into the woods or
something like that and then like a pro
you know big time like a bike a big
biker like a an athletic biker that
bikes fast came by and he came so close
to me that his shirt sort of rubbed
against me I mean that's how close we
were now had we hit head-on could I have
died I don't know I I guess is
relatively unlikely a bike bike head-on
collision it's unlikely that it would
kill you but it was pretty scary right i
mean biking in cities it's looked at as
the more healthy green option yeah but I
mean I used to the same thing in
Washington DC and my concern was always
that I was going to get car
ord yet some one while I was going
through the bike lane would all of a
sudden hit open their car door and go
flying and maybe even into traffic yeah
that is a concern the there's a sort of
other there's another approach to this
which is if you consider the conditions
that prior to vaccines and antibiotics
people used to die from I used to have
sinus infections bacterial sinus
infections pretty frequently when I was
like 18 to 24 it's very mathematically
possible that if we did not have
antibiotics at this point that one of
those would have spread and and
potentially could have killed me prior
to the antibiotic age I don't know i
mean the child mortality rate was far
higher than it is now and of course life
expectancies going up the story that i
would share is that when i was this is a
few years ago the Boston Marathon
attacks I was walking for my job near
fenway park to my dormitory in the
downtown area boston and because of the
the bear thon is a lot of chaos and i
didn't want to take the train home so i
decided to walk the whole way right and
so i would see the end of the finish
line i walked by the finish line at the
race time where was like 350 three hours
and 50 minutes and I learned later that
the the bombs went off at 409 right so
you know I I don't want to say this as
if that was in any sort of imminent
danger because only a few people
actually passed away from this but it
was certainly scary looking back at it
you were very close time wise and
location wise to where people that were
not doing anything other than just at
the race were killed because of where
they were and the time that that the
explosion happened so in that sense you
were certainly in a situation where
people did die doing nothing different
than what you were doing just walking
through I think that's the point
absolutely and a lot of people were
coming from the fenway area to the Red
Sox game that they have on patriots days
during that morning and a lot of people
that were injured or just observed the
whole chaos were coming right from the
game yeah and patriots day for people
who don't know it's a it's a
massachusetts only holiday only if it's
the first or is the second monday in
april or something like that it's early
in April yeah